the phone companies sprint shut down a
cell phone tower on the campus of a
California elementary school after some
parents said it may be linked to several
recent cases of childhood cancer
now those families at Weston Elementary
School in ripping claim the tower could
have exposed their kids to harmful
radiation Sprint says the tower is safe
and has operated well below federal
safety limits but the company turned it
off anyway and plans to move it to a new
location Carter Evans spoke to the
families at the center of the
controversy my son missed growing up
with his friends my son lost all of his
air it's not something that I wish on
anybody to watch their child go through
what our children have gone through
Kelly Prime's son Kyle was just 10 years
old when he was diagnosed with kidney
cancer in 2016
five months later Kyle's friend and
classmate Mason furrow Lee developed
brain cancer 14 hours to get the tumor
out and he had five weeks of inpatient
rehabilitation had to learn to walk talk
eat everything all over again two more
kids at the school were diagnosed this
year at what point are you saying we got
to take a close look at the school here
the moment that I found out that Mason
had been diagnosed it popped into my
mind that something was not okay
the moms believe the recent increase in
cancer cases could be caused by
radiation from radio frequency or RF
waves coming from this cell tower
located on the elementary school campus
it is classified as a possible
carcinogen that tells us that there is
some evidence out there we're not naive
to the fact that there could be other
components out there other environmental
influences but the bottom line that we
feel in regards those towers it doesn't
belong there if there's any indications
that it's unsafe you figure it's not
worth the risk
absolutely the school district hired
engineers to measure the exposure and
concluded the tower met government and
industry standards in all respects and
posed no threat to student safety the
parents hired their own investigator who
found much higher RF levels than the
district did but still within government
safety standards sprint takes safety
various areas
we sprint Starman ordell says three
tests have shown the cell tower is
operating 100 times below the federal
limit let me just ask you flat-out does
sprint believe that tower could be
causing cancer absolutely not it is not
a safety concern to the community but we
do hear that community's concerns so
we're quickly working to relocate the
tower whenever you hear of cases of
cancer in a child obviously that itself
is alarming when there's several cases
in one school that's even more alarming
CBS News medical contributor oncologist
David agus says the number of cases
warrants further investigation but he
says people exposed to RF waves and
normal levels have not been found to be
at higher risk for developing cancer the
way to study this is to look at the
incidence of cancer in proximity to
these towers we have to look at epidemic
data but the data today both in adults
and children don't point to these
causing cancer the American Cancer
Society says there is very little
evidence to support the idea that being
near a cell tower might increase the
risk of cancer but it also says very few
human studies have focused specifically
on that risk do you believe the
oncologists who say cell towers can't
cause cancer I believe that everybody
wants to believe our government
technology is what it is and it's
growing and it's out of it's growing out
of control
thoroughly son's cancer has returned and
he's now undergoing treatment crime son
Kyle is in remission but he still
undergoes scans every three months I've
looked into his eyes and I have looked
at the fear that he has as a nine year
old facing something asking me mom am I
gonna die it would it would push any
parent to fate I won't stop until it's
done until that thing is gone for CBS
this morning Carter Evans Ripon
California she's right about that the
school district tells CBS News it has
been in touch with the California
Department of Health and has tested the
school soil and water as well now it is
waiting for the results of those tests
but you can believe any parent is going
to will not stop until they find the
answer of some
harming their children and it has to be
hard to hear there's no connection no
connection while you're sitting here
looking at your child who's losing his
hair and is very ill yeah I'm glad
they're testing the soil and the water
and taking a bigger look I am too